Think about it,
all those who were listening to me tonight,
imagine that there will be 50% abstention.
People who think thating is,
uh.
Getting the system to fuck up.
But no,
he is pleased.
If there is 60% abstention,
Macron will congratulate himself
because it means that they are dealing with
1 people who give up.
That's what.
That's what you have to understand.
And I invite all abstentionists here,
those who are fed up,
those who consider that the politicians the
are constantly deceiving,
which is true.
I return my video to just,
uh.
The fake ass ball.
We are not like that.
It's been 17 years since people could measure who I am
and I always say what I do,
and that I always do what I say.
So,
I am calling on abstentionists here,
give us our chance,
test us.
Come on,
mobilize.
Imagine that 20,
25% of French people,
rather than staying home
on their couch or playing video games,
they say to themselves, here,
I'm going to go fuck Macron,
but fuck Macron,
it's not voting bardela,
right?
Because otherwise we would never talk about Bardella.
Bardela,
he is part of the system.
They screwed Macron,
went to vote for the UPR.
Because if,
for example,
the evening of election night,
there was
20% of French people who came to vote for us,
listen carefully to what I am about to say.
Yes,
on the evening of the first round,
the only round besides the European elections,
to the surprise of everyone,
we made 1 score which was 15,
18, 20%.
The French political system,
it explodes.
Within the hour,
you will see the face of all the guests
on all television sets
that will make 1 head of hell,
and everyone will say,
we may have underestimated a little bit
the debate on the frexit,
maybe we don't have
quite invited Aslino,
and perhaps the other political parties,
eh,
the National Rally reconquer,
Republicans,
France insoumise et cetera et cetera,
will say,
boy,
now there's the crazy guy at the lake.
Abraalcore will still be needed
Decide on this debate,
on this,
on this question.
That's what's fundamental,
right.
It really is,
it is in.
Really.
The survival of the system is in your hand.
If, yes,
you decide to stay and do nothing,
nothing will happen.
If you decide to vote for the
parts you are used to,
habit of voting,
nothing will happen either.
The National Front,
They have had MPs for 40 years,
but if,
on the other hand,
bravo!
All forbidden,
All expectations are to act
and you will vote massively for the aslineau list
Up.
Imagine the heads of the animators
once again at 10 pm,
the pelotest ends at 10 pm,
at 10:05 pm.
10:10 pm,
he sees that
we make 1 great.
Breakthrough,
it will be not only 1 event in France,
but 1 event in Europe,
and even 1 international event.
I will tell you that it will be followed in Moscow,
in the United States,
in China et cetera.
We will say, here, in France,
with one blow,
the French people wake up,
is, I make 1 call.
This election,
it is very,
very important
because it allows you,
with finally little means to do,
to blow the whole system away.
And by the way, by the way,
if we have 1 fort,
1 strong score will show
also that the French do not want to leave
in the 3rd world war,
that we are preparing.
That's it.